[Music]
dying i think a lot of people just they
see you run and they say oh it looks so
easy you really look effortless but
before it gets to that point it's hard
it's like hard work
staying there out sacrifice day in day
out just dying this time when you're
running you just want to stop you just
want to give up like
to hell with this i just want to go home
the day when you get up and you know
what you have a training today you know
it's going to be intense like oh god
i don't want to go today but you got to
go
it's so hard and a lot of people don't
know
listen
work is behind the scenes
competition is the easy part
behind the scenes
is where the work is done
everything is done to
to get
to that one race that you need to run
[Music]
you know there were saturdays or fridays
where i'd give up going to a dance or
hanging out with my friends because i
had workout the next day
but those things that i gave up
you know were things that i wanted to
to help me get to my goal and and there
were times where i put you know i've
been put in uncomfortable situations
but i've used my mental power my mental
strength to push through it i think
that's how you you know you can look at
any of the athletes in the world
some of the best athletes the greatest
athletes in the world do things when
they're uncomfortable
you know everybody can compete when
they're feeling good happy excited
rested but it's the best people who can
overcome when they're tired sore
not in the great mind you know not in
the best mindset
and i think
mental power that the greatest athletes
have can push all the pain aside
you know and i mean like when i was
doing that navy seals thing it was it
easy for me to do it no
it was easy for me to climb over a 45
foot wall and look down not at all and
i'm afraid of heights
but
you know i said to myself i'm gonna do
this and no one's gonna stop me
i think that's the biggest thing is how
strong you can be mentally
i think that really shows who the person
is
so i think that's one thing that
separates the good from the greatest
[Music]
i have to tell each and every one of you
that it doesn't matter how
how old you are how young you are your
age you can achieve anything that you
set your mind to
and i always say if i can do it anyone
can do it and the reason that i always
say that because i didn't grow up with
things being handed to me i had to work
hard i had to dedicate myself and i had
to be determined and i was
even outside a sport it could be
education it could be business it could
be anything um
it requires discipline and hard work and
determination most importantly it
requires self belief because
like me some people might not believe in
you but
you have to believe in you and sometimes
you you're going to be your own
cheerleader and you have to be your
biggest and your best cheerleader so to
all you young athletes take that to
heart and never stop believing in
yourself and really always support who
you are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can use my words you can use uh
you know the inspiration that i try to
give but
any way you can uh
be great i mean doing what you love to
do
you got to commit to it
um you can't want something but not put
into work you know it doesn't matter
what you're doing in life no matter what
it is it could be a professional athlete
or it could be an artist it could be
a doctor it could be anything in the
world a president of the united states
but you got to put the work in and i
think if you put the work in the results
will happen organically
and most importantly you got to find
happiness too you know if you're having
fun enjoying what you're doing
then it just makes it makes it so much
easier it makes it so much easier to
just like you want to do it every day
because it's something that you really
enjoy doing and you don't look at it as
work
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here